you give a talk with somebody else's
slides you know and so I'm not exactly
the height of propriety but you know
that it has other people the jokes it's
very hard to work with them you know so
yeah
cage barks water or watching out there
he's been very good good postdoc you
know it's a very independent and you
know he was the one that's really been
driving this work you know so and we've
been doing a collaboration with people
in the Duke Medical School that was one
of the nicer you know attractions from
for coming to Duke you know so other
than ever he says oh you left the snow
you know it so but was to have the Duke
medical schools all about a mile away
and whereas in Cornell that's in New
York City because you know they don't
have enough people to experiment with
itself all right so so Jasmine described
the spatial Moran model and the three
theorems talk about what the geometry of
the Premal in the field and the
malignancy looked like and what we
wanted to do is to actually apply this
to something I mean the the words about
applications didn't really mean much to
the people that animals will apply
probability but I won't get into that
further he knows so so net natural
context is head necks going to cell
carcinoma I mean this is something in
the 1950s when this guys slaughter was
studying this was this it's a cancer
where it's a place where you can look at
it rather than stuff happening inside
your body but there was a cancer field
effect that around the malignancy there
was a pre malignant area and sometimes
you would get a second malignancy at
some distance from the first site you
know I'll get back to this so just the
talks that out of order in terms of my
own how I talk about it so then we
wanted to a model that sort of explains
this and the
see the three regimes in gentlemen's
talk address this so so collaborators I
don't know who the first guy is both
jasmine and Kevin at University of
Minnesota motivation a clinical problem
as this this picture sort of freaks me
out and so I think it dates from the
Rolling Stones or something that like
get your Yaya's out you notice I have no
idea
Mark Smith he's out there let me tell an
embarrassing story is like a congestion
with graduate recruiting weekend the oh
there's we had this math slam where six
people give tiananmen talks about their
research you know so so mark decided to
talk about breast cancer using many
pictures of what's there Pamela Anderson
from Baywatch as I said and this turned
out to be a great recruiting tool but
basically the fact that the graduate
director grad students jumped up in the
middle of his talking said this is
disgusting you know so and so some women
were impressed by the fact that you know
you would do that you know so doc you're
listening mark or watching it later and
then sir
next time you'll come on whether you're
six are not doing so we're focusing on
head neck squamous cell carcinoma not
because we got to graft on the Miley
Cyrus foundation who's concerned what
might happen to her tongue you know so
but anyway but it's an interesting thing
and I want to talk about the things
sergeant's are interested in this or
surgical resection you have cancer your
tongue and if you want to avoid these
things then stop smoking now because
that's one of the main risks factors
here so I think you're talking about
surgical resection and soon let's see
stick carp here
Brandon tread life had a nice
conversation he goes
well why would you want to worry about
the size of the reception you know it's
like okay if you don't mind losing your
entire tongue then you know you don't
have to worry about that but then you
know if you kind of too little you get a
recurrence well obviously you don't take
too much so then you know the question
which we want to address with our
research is what size surgical margins
should you have okay should have warm
people that if you're squeamish don't
look at the next cell you know so so so
mark I start to say yeah come over watch
watch of operation you know so there's
like five hours that were cutting this
is the tongue I don't think it's that
big you know in Murrells you know but in
the middle let's see that so if this her
black stuff in the tongue is the the
malignancy and they yeah they had this
rule of thumb they go by the centimeter
around it all right so and mark was
there for about five hours and sort of
left when they were still going so one
of the problems with this there's a
frequent recurrence like twenty to
thirty percent you know so whoops oh
okay it comes like one two five years
later so so here it's our happy tongue
friend who's gonna be with us the entire
talking them so so here was the primary
cancer you resected it and then you
didn't take enough so there was the
local recurrence nearby okay so at this
point you want to go back to Jasmine's
talk where we were talking about math
here so so in jasmine stock that were
the wild-type cells the pre malignant
transformation and then there's the
tumor I have no idea what all these
slugs are for right so and this is out
of Jasmine's top you know cancer is a
multi-stage process you know so and one
of the things that you know it was
wrecked and you're questioning like I
Thunder saying
this is ridiculous model but it's
ridiculous model because it only has
like two stages so you have Julie a
cascade of several stages and colon
cancer which grows slowly and they have
lots of information there probably four
stages and one of the first work was
done by Armitage in Dalton 50s
estimating number of stages from slopes
of incidence theta and from seer okay so
I have no idea what so the thing is the
problem is field characterization this
is a notion that around the malignancy
is a transformed field or pre malignant
cells okay well that's clever I said
something it's not visible to the
surgeon and it's like it's not like the
the tongue is red and then it's orange
and then there's this black stuff in so
you know these are surgeon etic changes
that happen in the south that don't
affect them in a visible way
alright so dasn't mission is talk is
that epithelial cells I mean not only
for our skin but the lining of various
ducts and stuff the breast cancer ducts
I mean the cervix that you Burris the
bladder you know these are tissues that
divide a lot and cells that divide a lot
are more prone to the genetic mutations
that turn into cancer and then there are
lots of areas where you have potential
for field cancer ization them and
there's an interesting data set that we
looked at one point but got distracted
from bladder cancer when they looked at
genetic diversity of the cancer right so
all right so and again the sort of the
questions are how big margin is there
another field presently diagnosis which
is actually probably hard to say risk of
progression
which is sort of surveillance protocol
and actually is we talk to the doctors
more and more is that you know they
don't worry about you know calculating
the risk of progression because you once
you get this
once you have one cancer they're gonna
be seeing you every six months or a year
for the rest of your life you know so
okay so can we develop a mechanistic
dynamic model to answer these questions
or as is often the case in mathematics
we have the model and we're looking for
applications up them up all right so
it's a recurrent picture you know so we
have as in Jasmine's model they're gonna
be like type zeros which are wild type
cells once which are pre malignant and
then twos
alright so many things are done using
branching processes I mean and you know
confess'd have done now I mean something
like leukemia where cells circulated in
the bloodstream that's a natural context
of course the leukemic cells are being
produced in the bone marrow so there's a
little bit of space back there you know
so so here's geometry matters and I just
can't get the same enthusiasm that
marked us here sub he also has 35 pairs
of shoes so you always say that's
different personality here I had two
pairs of shoes counting multiple not
counting Melissa Melissa TV announcer
all right so meanwhile the T smart to
show up to conference you know so so
this is the oral mucosa it's like you
look really really closely it's your
cheek I guess is what you would see and
we go ahead I don't not used to pauses
and I think so we're interested down
here at the bottom these guys that are
sort of stained purple they're the stem
cells I mean most your epithelial tissue
is set up like this these guys down here
which are the stem cells that produce
all the stuff above it for a long time
the dogma was that you have stem cell
they always divide into one
differentiated cell and one stem cell
and then the differentiated cells divide
a limited number of times and initially
they go out the top and this sort of
picture happens on your skin in your
colon you know lining your mouth I mean
down at the bottom you know have this
population that maintains the whole
thing and um this is in a sense an
intelligent design because all these
guys down here they're the ones you have
to worry about mutations in if you get a
mutation in one of these guys then it's
gonna be up and gone before it does your
name you know so all right and then in
the last couple years it was
demonstrated by looking at stuff on the
mouse up to the risk that you know
sometimes you get division of the two
and sometimes you get two differentiated
cells so you would probably go yay we
got critical branching processes coming
into this in here and so this is like 80
percent and these two or 10 percent it's
a model that you know so that actually
you can sort of see the motor model on
the mouse tail if you stain things
correctly so alright but that's not
going to play a huge role here or
anything look backwards mr. Tong is back
and now it has a square grid lathe on
that he's like just like most of you
when you look in the mirror a nose and
I'm staying over the durán and there's
this mirror I guess maybe that women use
for makeup and they turn around looking
at this like my heads are like a huge
size you know better but I'd still
didn't see the girth of my tongue here
so we're using this is a very simplified
model I'd be the square lattice it sort
of depends upon how you want to do your
models you know when I started talking
the Franciscan mcore about spatial
models and all these cells sort of push
each other around and you know in a
solid tumor yeah you get
a denser disarray of sir tumor cells
which leads to hypoxia and death of
stuff but yeah for some reason for doing
math you put these guys on the grid and
it's a good first approximation and you
know if we want to prove things like you
know funeral whoops if you're an
assistant professor at University of
Minnesota math department you might want
to prove things you know my eights I
can't get rid of me it's not whatever
unless they canceled my parking permit
all right so we have this sort of model
to Jasmine talked about you know zeros
ones and twos you know you have your
four nearest neighbors you know so all
right so you know you give birth at rate
equal to your fitness replace I ran the
neighbor chosen random it's probably not
exactly what's happening with cells but
it sort of models the composition so
movie one or in its own mm-hm
watch this fast here all right so no no
so this is going to be a simulation of
the basic bias rotor ball mm-hm
so this is type two type ones inviting
the type zeros and they sort of jump
back and forth and this is sort of what
the bytes rotor model looks like it's
not so much sufficiently excited I don't
want to see it again
you know something all right so then
next I'll show you twice if you're good
you know so so this one it's going to be
a bigger simulation and runs really fast
so try to watch it quickly it's going
back to that process on a larger length
scale
oops all right got to be ready when they
do that all right and we hope the cancer
doesn't go like that in real time you
know it's like that there you are who's
your telling your cell komninos side all
right all right all right I'm gonna show
some with mutations they sort of go
faster you really can sort of see what's
gonna happen you know we're gonna give
two phones and then percent run this
research starts out slow you know so we
were waiting for you were waiting for
time the time of the first successful
type 2 mutation oh there it is there's a
little one and surprisingly the low one
gets the mutation first you know it's
sort of uh say this so obviously if in
the stimulation it's an exponential
amount of time until the first mutation
establishes and then we get a mutation
to type 2 and then and then one more and
then sleep the rest of time this is a
simulation that starts with one thing in
the middle I guess I got tired of
waiting it has a type 2 mutation and it
has a second one right at the boundary
you say whoa what's happening I so I'm
not sure what the parameter riot or but
questions about the movies everybody's
comfy all right so well there was a
movie to sped up process add mutations
movie three and four all right so so
this slide was announcements talk you
know so zeros type ones the type ones
start to grow depending upon the value
of this gamma the game has served
intuitively the number successful type
one mutations that you need to get a
type to my fellow the fact that the
serve breaks down from gamma equals one
I mean well we have a game equals zero
thing so it's more mostly that's why
Jasmine gave the more precise
interpretation it's like how long a time
do you need
here to the waiting time for the first
mutation to get you know the second one
so when gam equals zero everything's
going to happen in the first type one
but this is a thing where I need this is
gamma sort of in between so I'm going to
need a finite number of these things
before something happens and then here I
actually got a second primary tumor in
this one and then so again the whole
thing of the delineating the three
regimes was trying to understand the
sort of genome so this is a situation
where you know you would have a primary
tumor and a distant field with actually
a second primary tumor happening at the
same time but you know I mean these are
probably not reasonable parameterised
because you know you don't want a thing
to do things with tens of eight cells
that take years and years all right so
this is sort of the cartoon on the
mesoscopic model you know so I don't
know it's just sort of the referees
drove us to this you know so you know
there was this complex you know like 30
pages that prove these stupid theorems
but we didn't really want to write 60
pages or something to do these things so
I mean it's fairly clear that the
Bramson group for the shape theorem
tells you this thing grows and has an
asymptotic shape alright so and they
don't want to be hassled by worrying
about fluctuations about this thing and
sort of a we ignore you know mutations
near the edge that might miss this thing
up and then you're the second field then
eventually there you go you know a
primary tumor and then eventually I'll
get a second primary tumor there so
model analysis all right so I said this
before I've normal cells pre-cancer
cells and milling themselves I mean this
is a real over simplification I mean in
the work we're doing now of more
clinical relevance you have the
different phenotypes that the cells go
through you have atypia dysplasia
carcinoma in situ and then full
blown full malignancy and we did that
because in many cases you don't know
what this sequence of steps is right so
in cold the cancer yes and but in him
next to him cell carcinoma they tell you
some of the genes are involved and at
some point we said you know why do I
need to know this I mean these are
phenotypic changes they happen at
certain rates so let's forget about what
gene was you know being mutated and
dimension D very cold one you know so
the equals D equals one on the shirt
there's maybe breast cancer ducks
although they tend to be about 40 cells
around the equals to would be sort of
the main one since a lot of epithelial
tissues like the edge of the bladder and
the cervix or two dimensions three
dimensions and then well what the heck
right for general D unless you know if
we find that somehow there's a relevance
of cancer to string theory you know
something all right so so we want to do
calculations for this this is why we use
the simple mole so here's the sort of
the timeline so we're in a situation
where we think that there going to be a
number of mutations that lead to the
final results alright so and something
that starts back here is bigger and in
our little universities things just blow
up like a little balloons alright so and
then the more recent ones are small and
then we have some idea about the
dependence on this some s you know so
and then inside this growing cone I mean
so you know you have these things that
in space-time they look like this and
you know when I have enough area in
these cones then I'm gonna get
space-time volume in these cones
I'm gonna get a mutation that's
pointless but how ones that have to take
all right so the theorems are very tiny
which is okay because you don't probably
don't want to read these things
all right so so the first thing is that
when the malignancy happens what size is
the field that it happens in alright so
here we have the size biased have a size
bias pick from there the joint
distribution of malignancies and this or
their initiator types of possum process
so we know what the sizes should be then
I get a size by [ __ ] I've been the one
I'm getting is proportion to its base
time thought and actually we were hoping
that Jim Pittman here had a student
named Tran who did some really nice
results about size biased pics in a
certain setting and we were hoping she
was gonna tell us something about our
setting but that their machinery doesn't
seem to what you know after talking to
Tran and Jim Pitman their best advice
was why'd you just simulate okay so
alright but anyway so not that I want to
ruin jumped 65th birthday here or
something but all right there are
formulas you know these are gonna be on
the test here so you basically you know
you can at the time of tumor initiation
you can tell what the sizes of the tumor
fields are a man this is you know looks
a little ugly but it's just like I have
a bunch of cones that are started with
sizes of all tied to a Poisson process
and when they have enough space type
volume they generate a mutation and you
know you spend a couple bucks you figure
out how to do this and you do this
calculation so it's easy for me to say
since jasmine and Kevin and Mark riser
did this calculation you know so but
yeah and but but what are the points
here is that you can do lots of
calculations and like this stuck you
know loop you know
maybe Steve will reboot me and get out
of it here so I can calculate the number
of fields their formulas for everything
but you know this is not you know 18th
century applied math there's something
like I'm gonna say oh the mean number is
2 pi times 17 you know so but here I'm
their formulas and they look a little
ugly but you can do okay I'll do the
numerical now the key insight thank you
mark give you feedback on track here
having a macroscopic microscopic
parameters influence the geometry of the
invisible pre-cancer field okay now
let's go back to the clinical issues
outlined in the beginning on it so mr
tong is back alright so how big should
the margin be to avoid recurrence from
unreceptive portion of the field until
he's been hanging out with doctors here
so all right so excision margin zero is
not a very good idea right
I mean so it takes a while for the thing
to come back this is years I guess so I
have no idea what the units are like
this zero centimeters personally I would
call that two centimeters but you know
you know me two centimeters is about the
same as zero centimeters and himself
four centimeters is a little bit better
six centimeters really does a good job
and time now to think about how big 600
meters is compared to your tongue you
know
yeah I mean that there there is funny
now there is clinical data that they did
all you can just you know doctors don't
wanna do math you know we we had a bunch
of people do we did two centimeters
moved four centimeters and these are the
results we got I think I think pretty
Robbie didn't go what's the operation
you know maybe me said talk to somebody
at Stanford Medical School I would seem
to think all the way down but yeah now
this is the margin yeah yeah I mean
these are i think it's just consistent
with the experimental results and this
may be you know the source of these
numbers it's one of these things that
when you get the slides yeah I can tell
you what apply me two of them to flight
three but beyond that I don't know this
is this is predictions from the model
yeah ha and you parameterize what's the
data that parameterize it like how do
you give you they mean you need you see
you do it starting by measuring the
mutation rates and okay so this is okay
so there's a bunch of seer data on
incidence versus time right so we have a
model that has damn doing okay long time
talk ins at 3:30 3:30 or so so in the
three-stage model yeah oh so this is pre
malignant
this is malignant and these are you know
I don't know we caná-- said this is like
this please yeah atypia these things are
sort of neutral so we have a good you
know from earlier work we know what and
sort of Steven Mosley's theses you know
what you know times are to the first
type two and type twos because this is
neutral and type twos are coming in at a
pleasant process so we feed this into
the front end of the work you heard
about in the last talk we can get
predictions for you know incidents
versus eight and mark use that to match
sort of mutation rates and selection
coefficient so there's these are all
sort of selection ones
this is 1 plus s1 and this is sort of
one plus s1 1 plus s2 so I mean sort of
the mutation rates and not only that
they sort of make sense from a sort of
biological point of view but when you
fill in the selection probabilities you
get sort of intimates versus time and
I'm not sure this is the best way to
parameterize involved but it's at least
done by comparison with would they
there's experimental data
this is always relative to these that's
why I write this seventh thing what
price to the guys that are you know in
the cell cycle actively divided right so
it's not it's sir a mile thing though
all right this they said it's sort of
the best you can do my minute service
it's like you know a lot of the sort of
more population genetics have come up
with very low values the selective
advantage it's also you can also fit it
with a sort of what they know about
progression all rights are the questions
these two questions a mutant right so
probability of recurrence and the
function of resection of margin dinars
twenty is not you know and that's a good
you know so unless let's see what scream
if you're already ninety I mean who
cares very so something else is gonna
get you before that you know so I don't
like to look at this crap but anyway so
your sixty well God good ideas you and I
something else before we cancer kills
you know so but all right so so you can
do these calculations I mean this is not
something that um you know surgeons
already worry about because they don't
operate in the world they're like oh
you're cured you know go home and
something happens calls later you know
they they still look at the patients
after their release all right so all
right recurrence a local versus distant
all right so this is the sort of three
regimes of the mob although this one is
a lot larger scale so this and again
these these parameters the parameters
simulation
don't have a heck of a lot to do with
the parameters that you really see in
reality so here you have the bikes motor
model in two dimensions when the size is
small has a very fractally boundary and
where you saw Jetsons talk the number of
boundary cells is like when it has its K
over walk a roughly times some constant
when it's sizes cake so it says if it
was a compact ball
it'd be like square root of K so this is
you know you sort of it's very fractally
what one would expect that if this thing
had grown up quite a bit before the
mutation happened it would look more
like a ball so these are probability of
local and distant let's go back Oh time
to local and distant recurrence
this is regime 1 where the mutation
happens in the first malignancy here
sort of regime two when there's small
number of things and then just have the
base of my cloth or about where the
healing is not that very very
interesting thing but this is when there
a large number of mutations before you
get the first malignancy I mean it's
it's an interesting mathematical regime
and you know actually one of the
challenges which the referees you know
didn't really understand this so we have
results that go across all these they're
no seams between the results you know of
course I find that often referees and
misunderstand some of the great points
of my papers you know simpler it's
probably how I write online itself
ironically in this world the sequel is
coming out before the first one that's
been accepted you know so it was a good
do they got me off the team actually
failed of the team
Journal of theoretical biology and
that's probably the way journalist Erica
biology works I should probably are
probably he's already on the line or
something right so so that work is out
and this ongoing work so these doctors
over in the medical school I mean
they're you know very excited we meet
with them you know about three weeks to
a month marks doing them it's gonna be
looking a lot of sort of pathology data
so you have to do this you know there's
this internal review board process to
get access with the data and he's
actually doing that and you know I think
I forget my quarterly as a surgeon he
already is more of a sort of researcher
or but I mean that's you know it's
somewhat I'm not fighting one year you
know we're sitting there having eighth
meeting in this you know these guys say
well you know this is really made as the
maths really made us think about this
process in different ways and then so I
measure the models completely
parameterize right yeah because then
there's some stages in the process that
seem to take a really long time compared
to you know it's known from lots of
examples that from initial mutation to
tumor is like eight to ten years but
we're seem to have a model that you know
I'm not sure it's parameters right that
from dysplasia to full-blown cancer is
like thirty years you know so which
would be good you know but if it's true
but I'm more worried about it all right
so again I sort of you know this is the
sort of more complicated model again I
sort of got straight away from my
outline and they want to didn't collect
clinical data and actually you know you
have the receptive thing and they the
pathologist had looked for you know
malignancies and you know surrounding
tissue and then again of course the the
Holy Grail is to be able to you know
look at you know patient
data or imaging of the tongue to be able
to say you know what what sort of
resection margins would be best right so
that mark loves the slide and no idea
like this it's cool but you know it's
just sort of his vision of what he wants
to do mathematical model informing
diagnosis treatment and follow-up and
you know from the other side that's all
right yes
yes in her situation you're doing with
gliomas so there's a initial MRI and
diagnosis there's a second MRI right
before surgery you really have a lot of
action in the glioma over that two or
three months so I don't think that here
you're gonna have that sort of
observation window I think even if you
sort of spin you know it takes two
months to get scheduled for surgery I
don't think a whole lot has happened
let me certainly you know looking at
surgery and clinical but part two which
is so certain post a focus is what as we
ease
these would have invited around and in
this condition the dress is healthy but
and recurrences is supposed to happen
come from these precancerous tissues
that
but without an explanation there's
something that person gives her mind at
the bottom of it is that I think
tomorrow's a sort of commissions the
macro moment or sets that belief pencil
behind we need leave behind as you
because environment Aries is ready to go
so
yeah this is a you know it's a type of
modeling that you know I'm not ready to
dive into yet I mean these sort of
hybrid discrete cellular automata where
you have cells usually still on the
lattice but they're interacting with
glucose and oxygen and I understand in
the next their interactions between
various types of cells by somebody
sitting so
yeah I think that's among well no it's
still it's well it's a race I mean it
serves like you know we have you know
obviously in the gamma going to zero
regime that probabilities one but I
think in here it's going to depend sort
of there's going to be a lot of
variability I'm I guess there's some
overall average probability but I don't
think this is easy to compute
sorry accepts or numerically I mean the
way to say goes is like you know okay
I'm going to look at you know the
initiation x ro plus some process which
is not a great gift also brought us here
I condition on these things I know what
the volumes are I know what the Joint
Distribution of this is I know the
relative probabilities are the first
thing being in the various things and I
give this expression which I value it
does but yeah so it's sort of I mean
this you know these expressions I again
I sort of flashed and bite favorably
quickly because that don't think they're
all that informative you know budget and
in principle yes but in practice you
don't get sort of simple answers this is
sometimes here
all right let's thank Jasmine again for
her clock half an hour before they will
talk about evolutionary games and